Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhodasa.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and fully self-awakened one.
So no hitch tonight.
We're going to get into the habit of rebooting the Ruta every week.
So that should stop the problem I had last night.
So now there comes a point in the discourses where there's a natural repetition of the teachings.
Not only is there repetition within the discourse itself, but there's also throughout the discourses a repetition of the teachings.
There's always something new added and a little nuance, you might say.
So this is the discourse on the cowherd.
It's number 33.
And the Buddha is at Anathapindika's park again up in Savatthi, probably his most favourite place.
And he's talking to the monks or to the people who are listening.
When a cow herd possesses 11 factors, he is incapable of keeping and rearing a herd of cattle.
What 11?
Here, a cow herd has no knowledge of form.
He is unskillful in characteristics.
He fails to pick out the fly's eggs.
He fails to dress the wounds.
He fails to smoke out the sheds.
He does not know the watering place.
He does not know what it is to have drunk.
He does not know the road.
He's unskilled in pastures.
He milks dry.
And he shows no extra veneration to those bulls who are the fathers and leaders of the herd.
So these are the skills you need when you become a cowherd, okay?
Don't all rush out now.
So now, of course, he uses these metaphors in order to talk about the Dharma.
So he says all that about people who are striving, shall we say.
So here, remember, every time I say Bhikkhu, it means anybody who's striving.
How has a Bhikkhu no knowledge of form?
Here he does not understand that it actually is all material form in whatever kind consists of the four great elements and the material form derived from the four great elements.
So we're talking about what we would normally call matter, the body and what it's made of.
Now remember these four great elements as they're called, earth, fire, water and air,
solidity, fluidity, elasticity, heat, cold and movement.
That's how we contact matter.
So it's not what matter is.
We know it's chemicals and subatomic particles and all that.
It's how the mind contacts matter.
And he doesn't know it, this poor striver, or a real striver.
And of course, everything is derived from that.
In other words, that's at the base of all our experience.
He doesn't know form, you see.
How is him skilled in the characteristics?
He does not understand as it actually is, a fool is characterized by their action and a wise person characterized by their actions.
Can't tell the difference between a foolish person and a wise person.
How does he fail to pick out the fly's eggs?
When a thought of sensual desire arises, the bhikkhu tolerates it.
He does not abandon it, remove it, do away with it, annihilate it.
And the same with thoughts of ill will and the same with thoughts of cruelty.
So he's not quick.
So a person who, when these thoughts come, are not quick to acknowledge it and say, I see you, Mara, you see?
Therefore not picking out the fly's eggs.
And therefore you're left with a wound.
How does he fail to dress the wounds?
on seeing form with the eye a vehicle grasps at its signs and features right gets gets attached to it even though when he leaves the eye faculty unguarded evil unwholesome states of covetousness and grief might invade him he does not practice the way of its restraint he does not guard the eye faculty he does not understate undertake the restraint of the eye faculties in other words
Remember, every act of attention is an act of intention, and therefore it is conditioning, right?
So once we've grasped that, every time we attend to something and we see it's unwholesome, we have to guard that sense.
We mustn't put it there.
I must take it away.
And that also means knowing not where to go, not where to look, even before you see it, you might say.
So in this way, he leaves the faculty that all these faculties unguarded and evil, unwholesome states of covetous and grief and grief.
That's that's the usual indulgence and aversion invade him.
So, OK, how does Abiku fail to smoke out the sheds?
Here he does not teach others in detail the Dharma as he has learnt it and mastered it.
So anytime there's an opportunity for us to teach the meditation or to tell somebody about the meditation or the practice of Buddhism, then we ought to do so.
Failing to do so is a lost opportunity.
I'm not so sure how that fits in with smoking out the sheds, but I'm sure one of you will email me.
Anyway, that's called smoking out the sheds.
He does not know the watering place.
Now, a bhikkhu does not go from time to time to those bhikkhus who blurt much, who are well versed in the tradition, who maintain the dharma, the discipline and the codes.
And he does not inquire and ask questions of him thus.
How is this, Venerable Sir?
What is the meaning of this?
These venerables do not reveal in him what has not been revealed, do not clarify what is not clear, or remove his doubts about numerous things that give rise to doubts.
So in other words, he's not going to certain peoples or places, or in our terms, to books and reading and audios and other teachers to refine
our understanding of the Dharma and, of course, our practice.
The Dharma is both the understanding and the practice.
The discipline and codes is, of course, our moral conduct.
How does a bhikkhu not know what it is to have drunk?
When the Dharma and the discipline proclaimed by the targetter is being taught, the bhikkhu does not gain inspiration.
the meaning does not gain inspiration in the dharma does not grain gladness connected to the dharma so when we are when we're practicing and we're no longer feeling inspired no matter how what level it is it might be it might be just you know point one um
You know, once we begin to lose inspiration, then of course we lose interest and the practice goes aside.
So in a sense, we've got to read, we've got to practice to keep inspiring ourselves, keep encouraging ourselves to do that practice.
How does a bhikkhu not know the road?
Here a bhikkhu does not understand the eight bone noble path as it actually is.
Okay, so you know that.
because unskilled in pastures here a big who does not understand the four foundations of mindfulness as they actually are so we did that when we did the four foundations of mindfulness um in the this discourse number 10 on how to establish mindfulness so remember that was mindfulness of the body mindfulness of feelings
Seven factors of enlightenment.
Pastures.
It's often talked about the pastures.
Pastures is used in the scriptures to mean where you should put your attention on these pastures.
How does a bhikkhu milk dry?
When faithful householders invite a bhikkhu to take as much as he likes of robes, alms, food, resting places and medicinal requisites, the bhikkhu does not know moderation in accepting.
So when we're visiting friends and family and they offer us biscuits, we have to be careful not to eat the whole packet.
How does a bhikkhu show no extra veneration to those elders?
Bhikkhus of long standing, who've long gone forth who are the fathers and leaders of the Sangha.
Here a bhikkhu does not maintain bodily acts of loving kindness, both openly and privately, the same with verbal acts and the same with mental acts.
And this is how a bhikkhu shows no extra veneration to the elders.
So that's more specific to monks' relationships to relationship to the elders.
But of course, it's just a general understanding.
It's making a distinction between knowing somebody who is in authority as opposed to an authority.
So when somebody is in authority, they are in authority over.
So that might be your boss
fear, of course.
But if somebody is an authority, then you look up to them and you respect them.
And it's acknowledging that, that you acknowledge this person's authority in any field of life.
It doesn't matter if it's the Dharma or not.
So when a Bhikkhu possesses these 11 qualities, which are all negative, he is incapable of growth, increase and fulfillment in this Dharma and discipline.
So now the whole section now repeats it all.
It repeats everything we've just been through, only on a positive note.
So finally, the Buddha says, when a bhikkhu possesses these 11 qualities, he is capable of growth, increase and fulfillment in this dharma and discipline.
This is what the Blessed One said, and the bhikkhus were satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So that's that particular discourse.
Now, this is the beauty of this little book that I think I've shown you before, Pressing Out Pure Honey by Sharda Rajel.
So here you see she puts those points very nicely for us, understanding that all material form of whatever kind,
Understanding that whether one is a fool or a wise person, one is characterized by one's actions.
Abandoning desire, ill will and cruelty, all evil and wholesome states.
Practicing restraint and guarding the sense doors and mind and mind objects so that greed and or aversion do not arise in the mind.
Teaching others in detail the Dharma as oneself has learned and mastered it.
going to learned ones and asking pertinent questions in order to delve into the meaning of the Dharma, gaining inspiration and gladness in the Dharma, understanding the Eightfold Path as it actually is, understanding the four foundations of mindfulness as they actually are, taking in moderation whatever is offered, maintaining loving-kindness, bodily, verbally and mentally, both openly and privately,
to elders of long standing and to leaders of the Sangha.
There we are.
So I hope that that has been an inspiration of sorts and that it will encourage you to continue your practice and achieve full liberation sooner rather than later.
So we can practice now a little bit ourselves.